Here's what happens.
Within about 10 seconds, someone says, "This is a fabulous idea."
And they have about three minutes before they pitch the idea to the class.
So the restaurant in the garbage dump?
What does that turn into?
Well, they collect all the food from Michelin star restaurants...
...that was going to get thrown out all the extra food.
...and they have another restaurant at a much lower price, with all the leftovers.
Pretty cool?
Or the restaurant that's dirty with terrible service?
Well, that turns into a restaurant that's a training ground for future restaurateurs...
...to figure out how to avoid all the pitfalls.
And the restaurant with cockroach sushi?
Well, of course, it turns into a sushi bar...
...with all sorts of really interesting and exotic ingredients.
If you look around at the companies, the ventures that are really innovative around you,...
...the ones that we now take for granted that have changed our life,...
...well, you know what?
They all started out as crazy ideas.
They started ideas that when they pitched to other people,...
...most people said, "That's crazy, it will never work."
So, yes, sometimes people were born into terrible circumstances,...
...and sometimes, luck is a lightning bolt...
...that hits us with something wonderful or something terrible.
But the winds of luck are always there, and if you're willing to take some risks,...
...if you're willing to really go out and show appreciation...
..and willing to really look at ideas, even if they're crazy, through the lens of possibilities,...
...you build a bigger and bigger sail to catch the winds of luck.
Thank you.